thailand's prime minister calmly taking
his seat ahead of the no confidence vote
in parliament despite three days of
debate prayer chancha doesn't look like
a man under pressure while opposition
politicians have tried to land some
punches the ruling coalition still holds
a majority
i have to clarify that since you accused
me of being unsuccessful this is
completely untrue
general prior has emerged as an unlikely
survivor in the turbulent landscape of
thai politics after leading a military
coup in 2014 he's remained in charge
both as a military man and since
elections three years ago as a civilian
prime minister
with a general election looming in the
next 12 months the opposition are hoping
a greater test is just around the corner
even
mr
prayud can survive
from the motion of no confidence
but i still have hope that in the
[Music]
erection in the next year
people will not support him
street protests against the government
and the monarchy have been silenced with
the arrest of protest leaders but many
people still object to a government they
see as illegitimate
and a poor response to the covert 19
pandemic and the rising cost of living
crisis is expected to reflect badly on
the government at the ballot box next
year public sentiments are going you
know running very strong against the
government against bayout
economic conditions are worsening so it
is uh very plausible and likely that the
opposition policies will do well in the
end general prior sailed through this
motion of no confidence with relative
ease but the cracks that have emerged
within the ruling coalition and the
suggestion voters are looking for a
change ahead of general elections next
year means this could be the beginning
of a difficult period for the thai prime
minister tony chang al jazeera bangkok